Hello everyone.
Welcome to the Lange Focus Channel,
and my name is Paul,
and this is mystery languages.
If you've seen one of these before,
then you know how it goes.
All play some audio of a language for
you,
or I'll show you a written sample of a
language and you can guess what language
it is.
And if you don't know what language it
is,
maybe you can guess what language family
it belongs to or what country it's
spoken in or anything like that.
And similar to last time,
today's samples were submitted by Lang
focus viewers on instagram.
So let's get into the first language.
Please listen.
[inaudible] am [inaudible] [inaudible]
they moose values and the mice can throw
cans.